we're learning new details about the
case of a u.s navy officer sentenced to
three years in prison in japan for a
deadly crash
lieutenant rich alconis is accused of
killing two pedestrians after allegedly
falling asleep at the wheel but his
family says that he lost consciousness
due to altitude sickness an exclusive
interview with cbs mornings alconis wife
says she's angry over the punishment
upheld by tokyo's high court this week
elizabeth palmer has the story
began as a hike up japan's famous mount
fuji for u.s navy officer ridge alconus
his wife brittany and their three
children ended in tragedy
driving home alconas blacked out at the
wheel and two japanese people were
killed
that was may 2021
lieutenant rich alkonis a specialist in
undersea warfare was found guilty of
negligent driving causing death
now just over a year later this
tight-knit mormon family at home near
the naval base at yokosuka is putting a
brave face on it but they've just had
devastating news when i saw his face i
knew that
we had lost alconus was advised not to
speak about the case so his wife
explained and we all sat on the couch
together and we said and unfortunately
it didn't go the way we were hoping and
daddy's going to have to go to jail for
a while a while is three years alconis
has lost his appeal for a suspended
sentence the judge didn't accept the
navy's assessment that he passed out
from altitude sickness in her opinion he
just dozed off and if he'd been tired
she said he should have pulled off the
road
are you angry
i am
i'm really angry
the u.s navy told stars and stripes
newspaper we are disappointed with the
result which we believe is uncommonly
disproportionate but japanese media and
the public may not see it that way
driving causing death can earn seven
years in jail here and there's a history
of resentment against the u.s military
which has more than fifty thousand
personnel in japan many japanese believe
it has shielded those who've committed
crimes from punishment they are taken
back to the base and into american
military justice and get off if not
scot-free at least very lightly i've
heard that argument and i won't deny
some truth to it that has
definitely changed over the past two to
three decades
and the family argues that certainly not
the case here alkonis has apologized and
followed japanese custom in offering
restitution to the victims family 1.65
million dollars
are there other avenues for
clemency or
absolutely what are they just a phone
call from president biden
he could call and say he's coming home
the other would be for
the u.s ambassador to japan
ambassador emmanuel
he could
request clemency on ridge's behalf
the u.s embassy has only said it's
watching the case
what do you know about when
ridge will have to leave the house and
go to jail
um
he will be reporting on july 25th at 1pm
so i'm grateful
he'll be home for my daughter's birthday
before he goes
family time has never felt so precious
the clock is ticking
for cbs mornings i'm elizabeth palmer in
tokyo
well he'll be there for that last
birthday but if things continue as they
stand now he'll miss the next three he's
got the support of his family certainly
and also the support of the u.s navy